a YouTuber managed to infiltrate a
crypto scam that was hacking YouTube
channels after gaining the scammers
trust they claim they have uncovered the
most prolific scamming Collective on
YouTube let's take a look
hey everyone it's Liz just a reminder
that one button you can trust to click
is our like button our subscribe button
and our notification Bell cheers baby
dear viewers I need you to buckle up for
a wild tale of Deceit investigation and
revenge and crypto scamming all this is
wrapped up into one tiny little story
that I will present to you today because
I love you all very much we've all
fallen for tricks and lies before
especially on the internet I remember
when I first got my college email I
clicked on a link and then I began to
receive over a hundred emails a minute I
personally have never been reached out
to by a scammer that wasn't the case for
Sully G however Sully aka the real Sully
G is a musician that focuses on
automatone covers like this
Sully uploaded a video on their second
channel on Wednesday talking about their
encounters with a scammer in their video
on Twitter thread on the situation Sully
explained that they were reached out to
by someone named Thomas Elmers from
somatic FM for a sponsorship opportunity
so once I formally signed on to this
integration he sent over a GitHub link
that had more information along with a
download link for the product now
already alarm Bells were ringing in my
head because normally when you do a
sponsorship with a company you download
the product directly from their website
not from a random GitHub link so
nevertheless I tried downloading the
file and lo and behold my PC was like
nope don't download this this is a virus
so I sent Thomas another email saying
hey your program got caught by my
firewall and I want more information to
prove that you are who you say you are
because I was starting to have my doubts
his response was hey just disable your
firewall and run the program anyway and
I was never gonna do that that is one
step too far for me so around the same
time this was happening my friend Finn
MK had his channel hacked then actually
released a video talking about the
situation and said at the very beginning
that they were reached out to by you
guessed it Thomas Elmer's from somatics
FM Sully understandably upset by this
Revelation reached out to the scammer
and basically said f off and that is the
end of our story no it is not I 100 lied
to you the scammer responded I make my
living too bro sorry zero hate to you
Sully then decided to engage with the
scammer and they learned that the
scammer is a musician that's currently
saving up money to be able to pursue a
career in the United States when Sully
was like you're harming other musicians
with this scam the scammer said back
tell me please is it really that much
harm we do not engage in blackmail we do
not withdraw money from YouTubers
wallets we exclusively sell the channel
to buyers and after a couple of days it
is restored of virtually no loss it's so
awful so he put out a tweet warning
people by the scam and then one month
went by Mr business over here I mean Mr
Moneybags comes up with a genius idea
and sends me an email he wants me to
knowingly download the virus basically
rent my channel to him and then he'll
split the money with me so now I'll
actually make fifteen hundred dollars
sure genius no notes I of course turned
that down because I'm not an idiot and
that was the last I heard from Thomas
Elmer's until over two months later Mr
Elmer's reaches out and kindly asks me
to delete my tweet that exposed his scam
his reasoning being because it was
alerting potential victims that it was
in fact a scam who said Twitter couldn't
do any good the boldness of this scammer
is something but would they be so bold
to accept Sully's requests for an
interview yes they accepted police
request for an interview Sally learned
they are a music producer from Russia
and about the logistics of the scam I
became here from dark Forum a really
really long time ago maybe something
like two years ago and I did a lot of
things in this Camp community and now I
am in virgin and I just bring channels
to Stealers there is a file that you run
on your PC that comes to us and then we
sell the channel to cryptoscam streamers
for a really big amount sometimes
cameraman lays out the fact
and the following this is not a two guys
you're not going to twist it I'm just
saying what they said the scammer said
that they send about 100 to 200 emails a
day and 50 of people download the
product they said they don't feel bad
because Google support restores all
channels that fall victim so it isn't a
big loss they explained how once a
channel is hacked the stream goes live
and people particularly in the US send
money to the stream and don't get
anything in return to quote skammer man
people really believe in these giveaways
at the end of the interview Sully asks
very kindly this camera has any
questions for Sully scammer man asks
Ellie if they know anyone named cg5
Sally is like yeah why and it turns out
skimmerman is a huge fan and wants to
collaborate with cg5 Sally says that
since that interview scammer man has
asked them once a week if cg5 has
listened to their music that may seem
like a funny point but it's actually
important for later it's a surprise tool
that can help us later scammer man
offered Sully fifty hundred dollars to
collaborate with them Sully never agreed
jumat Sully said yes to being a covert
operator a virtual non-lethal Hitman can
you be a non-lethal Hitman basically
Sully gained the scary man's trust and
then got access to everything what was
Sully's cover story everyone needs a
cover story results and discretion are
my specialty I lied and told him that I
was running low on money and needed to
earn some extra cash so I asked him if I
could be part of his scam he said yes he
added me to all of their group chats
which gave me all the information all
the viruses they've been sending out
every payout made over the last six
months and also the names and contact
information of every single person
involved the CIA MI5 they could never
but like a good covert operator does
Sally has passed along the information
to the proper authorities after Sully
released the video they're removed from
the group chats and that is the end of
this story no it is not guys come on you
you got to keep up if I keep on tricking
you you're gonna fall for all the scams
out there come on keep up remember how I
told you to keep in mind that skimmer
man is a big fan of cg5 and wants to
collaborate with them I'm very sad to
report that that collaboration did not
end up happening but Sully's
collaboration with cg5 and their friend
Finn who fell victim to the scam yeah
that one's live they made a diss track
at the end of the video
[Music]
and finally we have concluded our tale
of Sully and their expose of a scammer
no jokes a sign this is actually the end
I know a lot of you might be up and
coming content creators and a lot of you
will be approached by some legit some
not companies promote their product or
service not everyone is going to have
your best interests in mind recently I
just did a story involving Slicker and
him scamming his own viewers to pay off
his gambling debts recently there was
news that there was a steam fishing scam
these are everywhere we may be on the
internet but all it takes is one wrong
move when our guard is down but you dear
viewer be careful there is no such thing
as being too cautious too Factor
authenticated everything don't click on
links you don't 100 absolutely trust and
above all else
call on Mama Liz to take care of things
I will straighten some scammers out for
you
oh easy one don't pick up a number you
don't recognize on your phone if someone
actually got your number for someone who
needs to get in contact with you they
will call you again like right away they
will like triple call you if they need
to if a scammer calls you and you don't
pick up they're not gonna call you back
to be like wait can you please like no
you're fine just be careful out there
babes all right